colfax avenue here in denver colorado
was once called the longest wickedest
street in america
my office is there in the same place
it's a medical desert
there are government clinics and
hospitals nearby but they're not enough
to handle the poor who live in the area
by poor i mean those who are on medicaid
not just for the homeless twenty percent
of this country is on medicaid
if your neighbors have a family of four
and make less than thirty three thousand
a year then they can get medicaid
but they can't find a doctor to see them
a study by merit hawkins found that only
20 of the family doctors in denver take
any medicaid patients
and of those 20 some have caps like five
medicaid patients a month
others make medicaid patients wait
months to be seen
but will see you today if you have blue
cross
this form of classist discrimination is
legal
and is not just a problem in denver
almost half the family doctors in the
country refuse to see medicaid patients
why
because medicaid pays less than private
insurance and
because
medicaid patients are seen as more
challenging
some show up late for appointments some
don't speak english and some have
trouble following instructions
i thought about this
while in medical school
if i could design a practice that caters
to low-income folks instead of avoiding
them
then i would have guaranteed customers
and
and very little competition
so
after residency i opened up shop doing
underserved medicine not as a non-profit
but as a private practice
a small business seeing only resettled
refugees
that was six years ago and since then
we've served 50 000 refugee medical
visits
[Music]
ninety percent of our patients have
medicaid and most of the rest we see for
free
most doctors say you can't make money on
medicaid but we're doing it just fine
how
well if this were real capitalism then i
wouldn't tell you because you'd become
my competition
but i call this bleeding heart
capitalism
and we need more people doing this not
less so here's how
we break down the walls of our medical
maze by taking the challenges of
medicaid patients turning them into
opportunities and pocketing the
difference the nuts and bolts may seem
simple but they add up
for example we have no appointments
we're walking only
of course that's how it works at the
emergency room at urgent cares and
at taco bell
but not usually at family doctor's
offices
why do we do it
because nasra can't call for an
appointment
she has a phone but she doesn't have
phone minutes
she can't speak english and she can't
navigate a phone tree
and she can't show up on time for an
appointment because she doesn't have a
car she takes the bus and she takes care
of three kids plus her disabled father
so we have no appointments she shows up
when she wants
but usually waits less than 15 minutes
to be seen
she then spends as much time with us as
she needs
sometimes that's 40 minutes usually it's
less than five
she loves this flexibility it's how she
saw doctors in somalia
and i love it because i don't pay staff
to do scheduling and we have a zero
no-show rate and a zero late show rate
it makes business sense
another difference is our office layout
our exam rooms open right to the waiting
room our medical providers room their
own patients and our providers stay in
one room instead of alternating between
rooms
cutting steps cuts costs and increases
customer satisfaction
we also hand out free medicines right
from our exam room over the counter ones
and some prescription ones too
if nasra's baby is sick we put a bottle
of children's tylenol or amoxicillin
right in her hand she can take that baby
straight back home instead of stopping
at the pharmacy
i don't know about you but i get sick
just looking at all those choices
nasra doesn't stand a chance in there
we also text patients
we're open evenings and weekends we do
home visits we've jumped dead car
batteries
with customer satisfaction so high we've
never had to advertise
yet are growing at 25 a year
and we've become real good at working
with medicaid since it's pretty much the
only insurance company we deal with
other doctors offices chase 10 insurance
companies just to make ends meet
that's just draining
a single-payer system is like monogamy
it just works better
of course
medicaid is funded by taxpayers like you
so you might be wondering how much does
this cost the system
well we're cheaper than the alternatives
some of our patients might go to the
emergency room which can cost thousands
just for a simple cold
some may stay home and let their
problems get worse
but most would try to make an
appointment
at a clinic that's part of the system
called the federally qualified health
centers
this is a nationwide network of safety
net clinics that receive twice as much
government funding per visit than
private doctors like me
not only they get more money but by law
there can only be one in each area
that means they have a monopoly on
special funding for the poor
and like any monopoly there's a tendency
for costs to go up
and quality to go down
i'm not a government entity i'm not a
non-profit
i'm a private practice i have a
capitalist drive to innovate
i have to be fast and friendly
i have to be cost effective and
culturally sensitive
i have to be tall dark and handsome
and if i'm not i'm going out of business
i can innovate faster than a non-profit
because i don't need a meeting to move a
stapler
and
really none of our innovations are new
or unique we just put them together in a
unique way to help low-income folks
while making money and instead of taking
that money home i put it back into the
refugee community as a business expense
this is mango house
my version of a medical home
in it we have programs to feed and
clothe the poor an after-school program
english classes churches dentists legal
help mental health and the scout groups
these programs are run by tenant
organizations and amazing staff but all
receive some amount of funding
from profits from my clinic
some call this
social entrepreneurship
i call it social service arbitrage
exploiting inefficiencies in our health
care system to serve the
poor we're serving 15 000 refugees a
year at less cost than where else they
would be going
of course there's downsides to doing
this as a private business rather than
as a non-profit or government entity
there's taxes and legal exposures
there's changing medicaid rates and
specialists who don't take medicaid
and there's bomb threats
notice there's no apostrophe so it's
like we were going to blow up all your
refugees
we were going to blow up all your
refugees but then we went to your
english class instead
now you might be thinking this guy's a
bit different
uncommon
a communal narcissist
a unicorn maybe because if this was so
easy then other doctors would be doing
it
well based on medicaid rates you can do
this in most of the country you can be
your own boss help the poor and make
good money doing it
medical folks you wrote on your school
application essays that you wanted to
help those less fortunate
but then you had your idealism beaten
out of you in training your creativity
bred out of you
it doesn't have to be that way
you can choose underserved medicine as a
lifestyle specialty
or you can be a specialist who cuts
costs in order to see low income folks
and for the rest of you who don't work
in health care what did you write on
your applications
most of us wanted to save the world to
make a difference
maybe you've been successful in your
career but are now looking for that
meaning
how can you get there
i don't just mean giving a few dollars
or a few hours i mean how can you use
your expertise to innovate new ways of
serving others
it might be easier than you think
the only way we're going to bridge the
underserved medicine gap is by seeing it
as a business opportunity and the only
way we're going to bridge the inequality
gap is by recognizing our privileges and
using them to help others
[Applause]
you